If you are a hand knitter,
you may have heard of an I-Cord bind off.
Let's work it on the knitting machine.
Let's say you need to bind off an edge
and you want a decorative finish.
But you don't want a band
or a hem or crochet.
You want something a little bit different.
Maybe you've knit a sleeve from the top
down, or you want to finish off the top
of a pocket, or even
the neck edge of a sweater.
Begin the bindoff by removing
the live stitches on waste yarn.
Use a good, contrasting color
to make things easier for yourself.
Cast on three stitches
and set your machine
to slip to the right only.
Now this works on any knitting machine.
Push the carriage to the left
and knit the first row of the I-Cord.
Then push the carriage to the right
and slip the three stitches. You'll have
knit one row.
I'm assuming you know how to knit I-Cord.
If not, check the Knit It Now
video on the subject.
With the private or the wrong
side of your garment facing you.
Pick up the first garment stitch
and hang it on the first I-Cord Needle.
All of this is done on the side opposite
of the carriage.
So knit over and slip back.
This binds off the first stitch.
Pick up the next stitch and hang
it on that same needle.
There will always be three
needles in working position.
Don't increase any.
Pick up the next stitch,
knit over and back.
Repeat this across the entire piece,
automatically forming I-Cord and binding
off the stitches at the same time.
Here's something to keep in mind when you
work this technique.
You're adding rows to stitches.
Stitches are generally wider than rows,
so you may need to knit the I-Cord at a
looser tension than the garment tension.
Try this bind off on a swatch with your
yarn before working your final piece.
When you remove the waste yarn voila,
you have a neat and tidy edge.
Now let's turn things around
and work an I-Cord cast on.
Bet you haven't heard of this one before.
The purpose of any cast on method is
to create a closed edge for our knitting.
This technique is decorative
and it looks great on both sides.
Knit a length of cord a little bit
wider than your desired width.
Then carefully hang a single strand
from each row of the eye I-Cord.
Now be careful to pick up along a single
column of stitches so you
don't twist the cord.
This time we're picking up stitches
to rows and you'll want to pick up
approximately three stitches
hanging on three needles
for every four rows of the cord.
That's it.
Just start knitting and you'll have
a pretty closed edge that looks
great on both sides.
Again, all of this can
be done on any machine.
Let's take this one step further.
Why not use I-Cord  as an embellishment?
Instead of attaching this little lover's
knot after the garment is finished,
knit and knot the I-Cord first.
When you get to the desired location,
remove the knitting from the machine
on waste yarn or a garter bar.
Hang the I-Cord on the needles.
Rehang your work and continue knitting.
Get creative with I-Cord.
Use contrasting colors or novelty yarns.
Once you try an ICORD,
cast on and bind off.
Sure, you'll find lots of other
ways to use these techniques.